It's an inconvenient fact of po that we
have to spend an enormous amount of time
figuring out how to get our hands to
move in concert with each other. And
it's an even more inconvenient fact that
we also have to learn how to get our
hands to do separate things at the same
time in order to do things like
transitions or even specific tricks
depending upon what they happen to be.
So, how can you develop that hand
independence? I'm so glad you asked.
We're diving in in this video.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm giving you
five exercises for developing hand
independence to help you out in a
variety of different ways. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer, Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all of these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video. Okay,
so first up, let's clarify what do we
mean by hand independence? Well, when
we're performing most po tricks, like
say a butterfly or a thread the needle
or even a three beat weave, we're having
our hands perform the same action at the
same time. But we can change things up a
little bit if we wanted to do a
transition between the two. And that
means that one hand has to perform one
action while the other hand is
performing a completely different
action. It's hard enough to get our two
hands to move together, but getting them
to move separately on demand, that's a
whole challenge in and of itself. But
fortunately, I've compiled together
several different exercises that target
five specific ways that you can develop
hand independence and make it work with
your flow. Starting with exercise one,
driving style independence.
So, driving style may sound like Greek,
but really it just means that we're
talking about the relationship that the
hands and poi have together and how much
momentum the hands are putting into
them. So, for example, I can have my poi
going around in what we would call
extensions or pendulums or in in spin
flowers or even in anti- spin flowers.
Now, you'll note that throughout each of
these different moves, my hands are
going around in the exact same way, but
the way the poi interact with them is
completely different. Whether it be
acting as extensions of my hands or
avoiding going over my hands entirely or
performing more beats than my hands.
This is what we mean by changing up
driving styles. And fortunately, I've
got an exercise to help you develop
independence with your driving styles
that doesn't require you to know any
more advanced PO moves. It works like
this. So, basically what I want you to
do is I want you to start with one hand
spinning the PO outward and the other
hand performing a pendulum going back
and forth. Now, this in and of itself
may take a little bit of practice, but
think that you want to go ahead and move
the PO to one side and then move it to
the other side, one side, the other
side. Take this slow. There is
absolutely no reason that you have to
treat this like a race. But eventually,
you do want to get to the point where
you can keep a pretty regular rhythm
back and forth between them. Where the
PO that's spinning around is going to be
going down and around at the same time
that the pendulum is and it's going to
be up going up and over as the pendulum
goes back the other way. Got that down
so far? Cool. Now reverse. Which hand is
doing which? So I started off with my
right hand spinning the PO outward and
now my left hand is. Again, I am trying
to make sure that I line up the timing
of these such that I've got the pendulum
in my right hand going under as the left
hand po is spinning under as well. And
it goes back along to my left hand side
as the PO is going over. So, you want to
get in 10 reps with your left hand
spinning around and then you want to get
in 10 reps with your right hand spinning
around, switching up which hand is doing
which. This will set you up for all
sorts of nice things like being able to
perform transitions whenever you want to
switching between timing and direction
modes. And even better than that, it'll
give you a lot more control over how
much energy you're putting into the PO
at any given time. And if you'd like the
411 on exactly what driving styles are
and how we define them, I did a video on
that topic that I'll go ahead and link
to up in the cards as well as down in
the description. All right, so we played
around a little bit with driving style
control. Now, we're going to play around
a little bit with how we get big and how
we get small. Exercise two, volume
independence. [music]
So, when we first start off spinning
poi, a lot of the tricks that we learn
involve keeping our hands inside of a
pretty small space, whether it be
weaves, butterflies, or thread the
needles. We're essentially working with
our poi in a position where our hands
are tucked up right next to us in a
position that we like to call T-Rex
arms. But it doesn't stay that way for
long. we start getting into things like
flowers as well as windmills and a
variety of other tricks that take up a
lot of volume. So, having the ability to
independently control the volume of each
hand comes in real handy. And here's how
we can develop that. We're going to play
around with a poi hybrid. A hybrid is
having two different PO driving styles
or tricks being performed at the exact
same time. In this case, I'm going to
have a static spin going in one hand
while the other hand performs an
extension. That means I'm trying to keep
one poi in a very very small space and
the other one is eating up as much room
as it possibly can. Now the trick here
is that I'm trying to keep the two poi
in the same timing and direction going
around. That is split time. So I'm going
to start this off by having my right
hand performing the static spin out as
far as it can go to my right while my
left hand performs that full extension
and brushes past the right as it's
pointing back at me. Now I'm going to
switch things up and have the right hand
perform the extension while the left
hand performs the static spin. Looks
pretty cool in and of itself, doesn't
it? So to do this exercise, I want you
to get in 10 reps with your left hand
doing the static spin and then 10 reps
with your right hand performing the
static spin. Oh yeah. And also make sure
that you're testing this out going both
directions, both counterclockwise
as well as going around clockwise. We
want to make sure that we really get
this down in all the different ways that
we can perform it, right? And of course,
this is going to be really handy for
learning other hybrids down the line,
like say taking that same static spin
versus extension and performing it as an
antibrid or performing isolation versus
cat eye. There's actually a lot of po
hybrids out there that are contingent on
one hand performing a trick in a smaller
space than the other one. So, get down
that volume control early and make sure
that each hand can perform independently
there. So, with exploring volume comes
another type of po control that we're
going to have to learn independence for.
And that one is [music] exercise three,
levels independence.
So, I don't know if you caught this or
not, but some of those bigger tricks
that we play with that eat up a lot of
volume, well, they also involve changing
the levels of our hands at different
places along the move. So, for example,
in this flower right here, my hands are
not just exploring a big space, they're
also going high and low. The same is
true if we play around in one of these
big windmills called poetry and man. So
it can be helpful to make sure that our
hands have control over being able to
spin the poi any way we want, both high
as well as low, and being able to switch
back and forth between them. So here's
an exercise that'll surely noodle your
noggin. Let's start off with that
windmill that I keep demonstrating.
Notice how both of my hands are going
around in a big circle in front of me
and exploring a range of movements going
from high to low. Well, what if I made
it a rule that only one hand could do
that at any given time? I could go
through a bunch of reps like this and I
can also pause my hand down below and
make sure that each hand gets in a few
reps at different levels before coming
right back into the move and bringing it
up high and tight next to my ears. Now,
let's do that with the other hand. So,
now the right hand is going to travel
around in a big circle while the left
stays up next to my ears. By the way,
please make sure that you keep your
timing and direction consistent in this.
And just like with the left hand, we're
going to pause it down below. Keep that
split time, same direction going with my
right hand down, and then bring it back
up and around. So, the exercise here is
to start up high, choose just one hand
to do those level changes with, pause
with it on bottom, and then come right
back into the move. [snorts] Then you
switch up which hand is doing which with
one hand doing the big move and pausing
down below and then coming back up and
then bringing them both up high.
Goodness. So this is going to come in
real handy if you want to play around
with say oh I don't know some of those
hybrids that involve having one hand in
a behind the head position while the
other one is down below. Uh, it'll also
come in handy for being able to play
around with different hybrids that
involve switching back and forth from
high to low in different patterns. Uh,
it's even handy for that hybrid that we
played with in the last example where we
switch between static and extension, but
you just happen to make those positions
top and bottom rather than side to side.
There's a lot of applications here.
Cool. So, we've explored driving style
independence, volume independence,
levels independence. What else might
there be? Exercise four, beat [music]
independence.
Okay, so this is an extension of
something that I like to call beat
control. Namely, beat control is being
able to determine how often the PO
complete a beat. Rather than just like
automatically finding a rhythm that the
PO spin in, we can control how often and
when we get the PO to complete a beat
around our hands, which also means that
we then have to look at being able to
control that independently between each
hand. How do we go about doing that? I'm
so glad you asked. All right, so this
one's going to be kind of an odd one, so
stick with me through it. I want you to
start off by taking your hands and poi
around in extensions that are going
together. same in your counterclockwise
direction relative to you. Now, as you
do this, I want you to go ahead and add
two pedals with your right hand poi. So,
now you have your hands continuing to go
around together, same, but you're now
performing a hybrid. That is the right
hand is doing a two pedal inspin flower
and the left hand is doing an extension.
So, we have added a whole bunch more
beats with the right hand while the left
hand is continuing to stay just as it
is. Switch direction two clockwise. And
now add those same beats with the left
hand. You want to try and make sure that
you have the ability to add and remove
beats with each hand independently and
be able to keep them moving together.
Goodness. Get in 10 reps going both
counterclockwise as well as clockwise
with this exercise. Being able to add
and subtract beats with each hand. And I
hope it doesn't come as any great shock
to you then that this sets you up for a
variety of what are called poly rhythm
hybrids. Things like the Mercedes or
Triricetra versus Pendulum. There's a
lot of different examples out there and
this helps set you up for it by being
able to control independently how many
beats each hand does in the course of
the move. Fabulous. Now, before I share
with you my final hand independence
exercise, I do have a quick favor to
ask. If you've come this far, I'm pretty
sure that means that you have an
interest in PO spinning, which is
awesome because poi is awesome. And even
better, I make lots of videos about poi.
So, if you'd like to see more of them,
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and ring the bell so you know exactly
when I drop a new one. Thank you so
much. And now after we've learned to
control all these different things
independently, what could possibly be
left? [music]
Exercise five, twist independence.
All right, so this is admittedly kind of
an unconventional thing to seek control
over, but I do think that it's pretty
important. See, whenever we're playing
around with PO weaves, we're essentially
working in an environment where we are
adding and subtracting degrees of twist.
So, as I'm performing a weave, I am
crossing my arms and then as I go over
to the other side of my body, I'm
uncrossing and then recrossing them. So,
I'm adding and subtracting a degree of
twist every time I go back and forth
between this weave. And wouldn't you
just know it? There's nothing saying
that you have to do the same number of
degrees of twist on each side. So, what
happens when we try to develop
independent control of them on each side
of our bodies? All right, so this one's
going to be a little complicated. Make
sure you're paying attention here. I'm
going to start off with my poi spinning
in split time, same direction in wheel
plane here. And I'm going to decide that
I'm going to start adding degrees of
twist, but only on one side of my body.
In this case, on my right. What that's
going to mean is I'm going to switch
from just having my po spin on either
side to crossing my right hand over my
left and then untwisting again. Right
over left, untwist. Right over left,
untwist. Right over left, untwist. Now
I'm going to add another degree of twist
on my right side, making it feel like
I'm doing a five beat weave and then
untwisting again. 2 untwist. 2
untwist. 2 untwist. Let's do the same
thing on the left. I'm going to go ahead
and twist over once and open. Once and
open. Once and open. And then go 2
open. 2 open. 2 open. Cool. Coming out
of this exercise, you are going to have
so much control over when you do and do
not add a degree of twist in all of your
weaves. Make sure that you leave all
options open for yourselves here. Sweet.
Those are five different categories by
which you can gain hand independence as
you're spinning your poi. I hope this
was helpful, not just for getting down
more po tricks, but also getting down
some transitions. Please, if you know
any other hand independence drills that
you're a fan of, leave me a comment and
let me know. Thanks so much in advance.
>> [music]
[music]
>> This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a huge
shout out to my FL patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you.
You all rock. If you would like to get
your name in the credits or access to a
whole host of other awesome rewards, you
can do that by heading on over to my
Patreon at patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing [music] up there. Not only
can you get access to all these perks,
but also you can help me out in my
mission of bringing po spinning and
flowarts to the whole wide world. So, go
check that out, please. And thank you.
And if you'd like to check out five
beginner drills that I have done for
learning hand independence, I will go
ahead and link to that video up here on
screen as well as down in the
description. Thank you so much for
watching this video. I hope you got a
lot out of it. Please make sure to get
out and flow today and I'll see you with
a new one real soon. Take care now.
>> [music]